[Music]
it may be the last day of e3 but there
is no shortage of new things to talk
about when it comes to the biggest games
even some that we've known about coming
for a while and Peter Brown here with
Jordan remai and we're gonna talk about
ghosts of Tsushima which we've seen
behind closed doors mm-hmm and we've
also got a chance to talk to Chris
Zimmerman of sucker punch who is
bullying one of the cofounders of the
studio and is also a programmer on this
game there's a lot of things to be
fascinated about Jordan what was the
sort of the one thing that stood out to
you the most so far I think the one
thing that really stood out to me was
the way that the background is just
constantly in motion like even if the
foreground is still the background is
just falling leaves or this clouds in
the sky are moving it's just so
beautiful yeah I mean Kristen Merman
made a point to say that you know one of
his goals is to have the environment
feel like the countryside of Japan right
- you know he wrote us through the force
on horses wearing the game that
character kept going he goes we're gonna
stop ya and we're just gonna look around
at the trees and and everything like
that and you're absolutely right
like nature things are in motion in this
game and it is simply gorgeous to be
part of they have captured ancient Japan
just beautifully it looks exactly like
just an old Japanese samurai film yeah
[Music]
and that's actually interesting you
mentioned that because Chris Zimmerman
is also saying like look we really want
to be historically accurate but he also
wants to play into the expectations we
have from samurai films and samurai
games so even though a lot of this is
based on 13th century Japan and the
location the island of Tsushima in
particular they are taking some
liberties to fall in line with our
expectations so armor for example it's
not authentic to the time period which
if you would think that that would be
one of the iconic things that would
stand out but he was describing like
it'd be way too boxy people would be
confused by that he doesn't want them to
be any jagged edges that are gonna break
the experience so they're trying to find
that balance between accurate and well I
guess accurate to our expectations and I
think they've done a pretty good job I
love the fact that when we went behind
closed doors he mentioned that there is
an option to turn on just Japanese
voices yes I was worried by the initial
trailer during the position press
conference but yeah that's really good
that's you quite minute
[Applause]
what do you think about the combat it
mean it's kind of a little unrealistic
that you could take multiple sword
slashes to the body it is very
unrealistic that was another thing that
stood out to me and it's and it's it's
sort of again find that balance between
looking like such a realistic game with
high stakes but then it also being a
video game where you can no fail but not
totally fail immediately like you would
if you were struck with a katana
Zimmerman said yeah we tried one hit
kill combat like something like Bushido
blade and it you know it wasn't fun
according to him and I can I can totally
understand that and of course Jin is
supposed to be somewhat of a superior
force to compared to those around him so
what do you feel that way if a single
sword slice killed him probably not so
that that is something that I'm
interested to see more of how that plays
out right now it does stand out to me as
something that I'm not totally sold on
just yet
it is really cool though I love the fact
that he talked about that this is kind
of building Jin's legend that he's the
last of the samurai on the island and so
the Mongolians are like we can't stop
this unbeatable foe and so he becomes
kind of the ghost and so we saw a lot of
stealth kills and types of combat that
you wouldn't normally associate with a
samurai yeah and he's supposed to evolve
I think into becoming more of a ninja
like the first wheel at Paris games week
made him look like more of a ninja than
the samurai exactly so what we've seen
here so that's gonna be a really
fascinating transition and of course the
Mongols are an important part of this
story too and some women you know I
asked him are they just you know just
bad guys is that it are they just one
note and he said no like we're not
talking about those details because
obviously we won't spoil things and
we're not ready to do that yet but it's
also nice to expect that it's not just
going to be Jin who will have a complex
evolving character the Mongols might be
and then you know in their own right
offer interesting stories and
seems that most of the stories are not
gonna be just painted in just broad
sprays of black and white like he spoke
about how just in that opening demo that
we saw for during a Sony's press
conference that that was just a side
mission and that our rally is just kind
of a character that meets Jen and she is
important for just that one section of
the game and even though she's an ally
temporarily like she also wants to kill
that monk that we have to defend because
he's an inspiration to the people yeah
when they're all pushed to the brink
like nothing is black and white anymore
right like people are put in desperate
situations and have to deal with them
and it's great to you know T both hear
him say and to see and that example that
you just provided that like it we will
be surprised by what the good guys
become and what the bad guy has become
yeah in his desperate time well thank
you for watching us everyone this has
been our little discussion I'm go sister
Shima there are so many other games we
have talked about 80 through 2018 some
of these things I still haven't seen I'm
going to go back to GameSpot to watch
them you should too thanks for watching
take care
[Music]
you